you know I've had the pleasure of
getting to know you a little bit
off-camera you know we were close we
hang out we hang out families hang out
our family your kids call me uncle Tim
my kids call you the talk show guy I
think they should learn my name at some
point I really do but your wife alexis
is absolutely lovely
she's lovely woman's beautiful she's
been with you since the very beginning
you guys met when you were practically
kids yeah we're like 30 years yeah I've
been through she feels like ten minutes
yeah underwater you know isn't wonderful
right now the kids are all two of them
are in college and then one's been gone
the last couple days on like a senior
trip of some kind and we had like you
know we had this whole thing we're like
this is gonna be what its gonna be like
in a year or two when they're all gone
and oh no turns out don't worry about it
that whole empty nest thing it's like
it's awesome you like it oh my god first
of all people think you're in show
business that somehow kids are gonna be
like isn't that great your dad's and
show business it's not it's the same as
any debt they hate you and they they're
not impressed no they are not impressed
no you know what I realized the last
couple days is there's nobody going dad
I can hear you as if I'm taking up space
in the house that I bought yeah like
that is nice yes my like a couple days
it's just the two of us and my wife's
like I'm gonna run a grocery store what
do we need and I literally said milk and
vodka and she said that's it I said we
have coffee yeah
it's like we didn't feel like we really
needed anything I gotta wash my balls or
something by the way by the way and I
didn't I hadn't planned it but T does is
good they say they say y'all vodka
tastes the same not as far as I'm
concerned t knows so much feed us good
so much people I mean I'm trying to you
know what I mean yeah yeah I don't work
a lot I don't I once upon a time in
Hollywood was at two days three days now
auntie taught honestly two and a half
weeks there I loved every second of it
I'm sorry were we interrupting you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wishing I am wishing I wore a hat like
that on the show I'm wishing I had a hat
like that on the show because I'm
noticing you get to do one thing but
then when you start to tell a story you
push it back and you get into the yarn
you're gonna tell and that's a move you
only see Cowboys do yeah I would do that
every time on this show I do the setup
to the joke so you can wash your bar
[Applause]
we all saw it when you when you pointed
out your props I was about to say don't
forget to have yeah yeah thank you I
appreciate that you know a guy down
production did you steal it from you
know what no he knows realize yeah yeah
but the same guy who who made the hats
for the shows that I've been you know
I've had the fortune of being in a bunch
of these shows where I work hats and
just walked around was cool right and
there's a guy you know what I'm gonna
just tell you I'm not even gonna make it
a cheesy commercial Baron hats
yeah but he's now downtown oh yeah I
moved downtown it's fantastic would that
make er you know what I'm talking about
they've been around they've been making
hats for everybody if you're in downtown
if you're in downtown you to go down
there you want to get hat sent you yeah
and I would like more free hats
yeah there's they're not cheap yeah I
don't think hats work for me if I wore
that hat eh I try is it okay if this has
been washed yeah all right I just threw
it on because I need a haircut it looks
so good on you and then I put these
things on
[Applause]
for you it's not the same you know what
I mean I got a giant melon yeah that
that looked like your dirt bowl of your
Dust Bowl farm got foreclosed on yeah
yeah they took the farm yeah I can wear
that hat in a tire that stops here and
overalls that's what I should wear
I still trying to think of that in the
image of you with the hat what's that
from it looks like that little animated
thing that I can't think of what it is
what's that I don't know but let's all
stop and thought it will cut it out
leaves no oh this is staying in this for
the world
we're gonna find it and they're gonna
because if you got some you got some
people here and there okay well-meaning
guy the cartoon what if it's just a
recent animated thing that's a guy that
means well and he's sorry his tractor
did all that damage it's lovely when you
come by the show I love being here your
and I have many people every time you're
on this is a comment I get from a lot of
people I don't if you've heard it as
well but people tell me they love it
when Tim's on yeah because it's you're
so loose it's almost as if I'm not
saying you've been drinking backstage
but you have the looseness of a man had
a few not being sold on the second
you guys pay attention yeah that's not
getting by me but it won't pop me no
blow where's who wears yeah
yeah
listen listen man you're getting on uh
there's no one better Tim Olyphant